des trains plus efficace des rames plus
moderne à une sécurité renforcée les
ambitions portées par le stif et la
région ile-de-france sont élevées pour
les transports en commun franciliens
mais alors comment les financer d'ici
2030 plus de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sont prévus nouveau
matériel roulant nouvelles lignes comme
le tram 13 dans les yvelines ou encore
le grand paris express
il faut donc trouver des ressources
supplémentaires qui pourraient déboucher
sur une nouvelle hausse de la
tarification pour les voyageurs ça fait
quinze ans que chaque année en moyenne à
2 5%
le pass navigo ou la carte orange
augmente donc ce n'est pas un sujet
nouveau
et oui il continuera naturellement
d'augmenter la présidente s'est engagé à
ce qu'il n'augmente pas ce qui est pas
ce qui était un changement avec ce qui
se passait avant parce qu'il n'augmente
qu'avec de l'offre supplémentaire cette
année il a augmenté enfin les derniers
avaient augmenté de 3 euros nous avons
eu de l'offre supplémentaire
en contrepartie ces salles engagement
politique est pris par la présidente
autre solution envisagée pour disposer
de nouvelles recettes des tarifs plus
élevés pour les touristes l'instauration
d'heures creuses ou d'heure plein ou
encore la mise à contribution des
automobilistes via un péage urbain à
l'instar du modèle britannique
on oublie de dire que sur les millions
de déplacements quotidiens en
ile-de-france pratiquement 60% se font
aujourd'hui en automobile donc il faut
prendre au sérieux l'automobile
peut-être investir sur la voirie dans
certaines zones et symétriquement
demandé à ces automobilistes de
contribuer d'autant que ces
contributions du type péage de
congestion ou péage en périodes de
pollution
c'est aussi un moyen de rendre la
mobilité plus durable un londonien peut
débourser jusqu'à 415 euros par mois
pour ses déplacements transports en
commun contre 73 euros jusqu'à présent
avec le pass navigo pour un parisien